* The names of the translators are attached in the video description below *
This is a motherboard for the Super Nintendo device: a 16-bit video game device
Released in 1991 in the United States.
These are the acoustic chips that worked side by side to create all sounds, sound effects and music
Which you have heard in super Nintendo games.
The first chip named SMP or SPC 700 was
The kernel processing enables the music programmer to play video games
From writing the program that tells the other DSP chip
Any votes he wants to issue.
While the original Nintendo Entertainment System sound chip had only 5 channels,
It offered only a few creative differences to the same basic voice,
The Super Nintendo had 8 special channels
The sampling system was used
Which means that artists were able to add sounds and vocalizations, which made them musical instruments.
The space is available for 8 synchronized machines
The possibility of sampling from various sounds, the Super Nintendo
Was a significant improvement over his predecessor.
But there is still one big handicap. Through the two chips, the device can only absorb
64 KB of audio RAM.
To give you an idea of ​​how small this size is,
The average volume of a 3-minute mp3 song you might buy is from the iTunes store,
Is about 6 MB,
Which is larger than the full capacity of the Super Nintendo 100 times,
This is for one song only.
She mocked 64 kilobytes in order to save all music and sound effects to the whole game.
So you often listen to music ... its quality is poor.
When you think about re-integrating popular music, you might consider someone you cut
Some seconds of old drum rhythm and use it in a new song.
But even samples that are a few seconds long carry a tremendous amount of information.
In order to take into account the space of 64 KB, the Super Nintendo music samples were to be slim,
Sometimes it is so small that it is just a circle of one waveform.
In order to produce good music despite these restrictions,
You had to be creative.
What you are hearing now is the "Aquatic Ambiance" of "Donkey Kong County" 1994,
Outstanding music produced by one of the best composers Video Games: David Wise.
Wise managed to spin beautiful music despite the limitations imposed by Super Nintendo's sound chips.
For example, the growing background sounds you hear in this track.
Such musical compositions were impossible on Super Nintendo,
The integration of something of such length and complexity would have exceeded the absorptive capacity of the system.
He had to think outside the traditional range.
One of the main features of the Korg Vision is the possibility of weaving a number of sound waves.
The waves are defined as single-circuit or multi-band rings with more than 400 internal waves.
You can select up to 255 different waves and play them in any order, including the choice of volume, duration and fading times.
The "Korg Vision"
An electronic sounding device released in the early 1990s that used something called "wave sequence"
To play a number of small samples in a quick sequence to produce distinctive sounds and growing.
Of course, Nintendo was unable to arrange and rearrange the samples on its own.
To achieve this acoustic effect, Wise worked hard to record individual waveforms at different frequencies
And put them all in one codec after another.
This program is called "Musical Tracker", where music is reduced to mere numbers.
Each little sound is placed on a vertical time frame and the columns represent the musical notes, the octave and the sampling options
Sound level and some minor effects such as sound propagation, flash and echo.
It took Wise five weeks to enter each sample in the Aquatic Ambiance section. It was a tedious process
But the results are rich.
The Super Nintendo was a restricted device for composers without a doubt. As with anything,
The constraints generate creativity,
And just because the audio system consists of only two chips, 64 kilobytes of RAM and a lot of hexadecimal symbols,
It does not mean that he can not produce beautiful music.